you
welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we are hosting
webinars every Tuesday my name is Tina
toshko and today we will be talking
about what's new in Google bigquery you
can ask questions anytime on the
platform and we have Googlers on standby
to answer them let's get started as I
mentioned my name is Tino and I'm a
product manager on Google bigquery I'm
actually being joined by Jordan tegami
one of our engineering leaders on Google
bigquery to help me with the Q&A here
there you can always reach me on twitter
at the handle down there and saying with
Jordan I'm gonna volunteer them for that
we love talking to our customers we love
talking to people who are using our
platform we want to know when things are
going well when things are not going
well we want to know what you would like
us to build next so please feel free to
reach out to us and at the same time of
course you can follow along with our
progress on our release notes you can
reach us on Stack Overflow we have a
public issue tracker where you can
submit feature requests and so on so
like we're even active on reddit and we
have lots of folks on places like hacker
news that are developer advocates that
you can have conversations with but this
is just another way for us to reach out
to our community and update you on the
things that we've been doing so far in
2018 well let's talk about that so far
in 2018 it's been five months we've
released 27 major features into beta and
general availability now these are major
features so a lot of features are coming
out that just don't get as much
attention but these are the things that
really our customers care about and for
every major feature that we release
there's probably a major backend feature
that you don't know about
so things that have to do with
improvements around performance
durability availability reliability even
cost right so the things that you may
not notice until you go and you push
that big red button that says run query
things just might work better the next
time and of course all these features
appear as they roll out right we we
don't have
maintenance windows we we don't restore
your bigquery instances and things like
that you just get features continuously
and if you don't know we are having a
major conference at the end of July July
24 and 26 in San Francisco we're all go
clap our form is going to be joined by
our customers or users you'll be able to
hear some product updates you'll be able
to hear from our leadership and some
user stories and of course you can
connect with other folks who are using
Google cloud platform so please come
join us
I'll be there shameless [ __ ] I'm
actually going to have two sessions
there in the first session I'm going to
be joined by Rick and Kevin from the
Home Depot where they'll talk about
their journey on using bigquery as their
enterprise data warehouse for all of
their analytical needs and in the second
session I'll be joined by Nicole from
Spotify GP from o'the Yahoo and a couple
of guys from Twitter Pavan and Roman who
will talk about their you know internet
scale usage of the query as well and
Jordan is gonna have a session as well
Jordan is going to be joined by a Lloyd
tab from looker the CTO of looker and
they're gonna talk about some really
interesting concepts around the quarry
so please come join us as well well
believe it or not the quarry has been
around for six years we went general
availability on May 1st 2012 it's
interesting because New York Times wrote
about this Google offers big data
analytics which is interesting we've
grown since then to incorporate lots of
other features and lots of other
functionality that kind of extend us
beyond the Big Data realm but you know
we've been at it for six years and we're
continuing to release more and more
features and again we'd love to hear the
features that you care about the most
and we have lots and lots of customers
were really you know proud of of the
customers that we have and the journeys
that they've taken with us you know
folks like Spotify as I mentioned before
in Home Depot and o'the and you know
there's this call these
folks are coming from all kinds of
backgrounds with all kinds of use cases
gaming clickstream analytics marketing
data retail and so on and so forth so
hopefully next year at this time your
logo will be on this slide as well one
customer that was profiled by Business
Insider a couple of weeks ago is Credit
Karma
we've been talking to Credit Karma for
the last two or three years they've been
using our platform for a while and so
they've committed to using Google for
all of their analytic needs and bakura
of course is a huge part of that Credit
Karma is a very sophisticated
engineering organization and you know
there's just really nice people so if
you see them please say hi to them
speaking of sophisticated engineering
organizations twitter has decided to
align with Google cloud platform for
their data and analytic needs as well so
Twitter of course is a very active
participant in the open source community
they saw very interesting internet scale
platforms and the fact that they're
partnering with Google probably says
something about it
so we'll be looking forward to working
with Twitter in the future so what does
2018 look like so far for Google
bigquery well these are some of the
features that we've released and I'd
like to share with you guys and ladies
what these features are all about I'm
just gonna run through all of them and
hopefully give you a good idea of how to
use each one well the first team I want
to talk about is
richness of functionality the query when
I first started was a sequel engine that
which is there to analyze data that you
load into the query but over over the
years we've added more and more
functionality to kind of simplify how
you manage your data and give you more
functionality around that so richness of
functionality is the theme I'm talking
about here the
as DDL got a definition language DDL
went betta a few months ago the GL
essentially allows you to inline in
sequel statements allows you to create
and delete tables and use virtual use
and one so just kind of makes it much
easier for you to work with your data
you can always do that using other types
of operations the one interesting way of
working with data definition language is
using create table as select so one use
case here for example is if you have a
table that isn't partitioned and maybe
doesn't have a specific column that
you'd like you can select from the table
and you know create new columns you can
filter data or actually select from any
query you want you can have joins you
can have analytic functions in there and
the results of that table can be written
into a new table that may or may not
exist and then you cannot a partition
that on this is probably the the number
one use case for data definition
language that we have so far so please
try it out we'd love to hear your
feedback on that the next feature is
merge so the query has had DML data
manipulation language for quite some
time now merge is a really powerful
operation that will merges the three
statements that are part of DML insert
update and delete so in one statement
merge you can do all the above so this
is an example of a merge query right
here and the typical use case is that
you might have a table that has all your
inventory and this table of course needs
to kept up up to date as new inventory
comes in you would probably want to
update your inventory table with you
know the new arrivals and of course if
there is a product that's in your
inventory you might want to increase the
and if there is not a product in your
inventory you might just want to add it
so this is what the statement
accomplishes and a quick little segue by
Cory and technologies like the query
that support DML right support mutations
updates deletes and inserts so the
quarry isn't necessarily a great
technology where you would want to do a
million individual updates and deletes
that's just not how this technology
works and any technology that similar to
bigquery has the same you know
architectural limitations but what
bitcoin allows it to do it allows you to
work on as many rows in a table as
possible with an one individual
statement so while we don't offer you a
whole lot of statements that you want to
make each statement can process
essentially trillion rows if you'd like
it to be we allow you to run correlated
mutations what I mean is by that is you
can update delete and insert rows in
your table based on some kind of
statement like a sequel statement so
here's an example there that sequel
statement can be any or any kind of
statement that can be joined you can
have aggregations filters analytics and
all that typical sequel stuff so again
while you could do lots and lots of
statements on correlate on mutability
you probably shouldn't and so the best
practice around the query is to batch
all of your updates the leads into
single statements this is of course
especially relevant for things like gdpr
where you might want to update your data
inside of the query so we try to make it
easy on you the next feature is actually
a data type numeric and marek is really
a decimal data type that has actual
precision so all the way up to 38
precise decimal points this is
especially useful for financial
calculations where you need to
where you keeping track of money
essentially it turns out that float is
not a really good datatype for these
types of operations people don't like
losing parts of pennies and their
calculations and neither is integer
because cents exist but with this data
type of course we extended all of our
sequel functionalities you can run
algebraic and arithmetic statements in
sequel on numeric so hopefully that
simplifies your life and let us know how
it works for you so we talked about the
features that enrich the functionality
of the query the next thing I want to
talk about our features that simplify
your life that allow you to have a peace
of mind when you use in bigquery the
first one this sea mech c-max stands for
customer managed encryption keys so to
take a step back the query by default
encrypts all data at rest and what the
bigquery actually does is it chunks all
your data into tiny little pieces
throughout its data centers and this
little chunks of data they're all
protected by their own data encryption
keys and on top of that we have key
encryption keys that are encrypting the
keys that are protecting the data so
that in some unfortunate situation where
data is you know maybe a disk ends up
and in somebody's hands data is entirely
useless to those folks because not only
do we chunk the data all around our data
centers we also use two levels of
encryption but we are the ones that are
managing your encryption keys so for
some situations our customers might want
to manage their own encryption keys so
you bring your own encryption keys you
manage them you can rotate them you can
specify these encryption keys you can
actually with one click deactivate the
encryption keys so that all data becomes
essentially inaccessible to anyone
including us so - it's a really
interesting and really powerful security
feature for
folks and finally we're keeping track of
all everything that's happening with
encryption keys in audit logs this is
our paper trail you can you should
probably go and enable audit logs today
audit logs keep track of every single
job every single query that has occurred
inside of the query so when a job
started when somebody access specific
data set these are of course immutable
and you can actually pop them back into
bigquery for analysis for the last few
years the quarry has been a regional
service but we've only been inside of
the United States and Europe but we have
lots of lots of customers in Asia the
primary reason for folks in Asia to
actually had the query in in the APAC
area is to minimize transit from those
areas to the United States or to Europe
because that a transfer can be you know
can have an additional cost latency wise
it's not a huge consideration because
you know B query takes a second to
process a query what's another 100
milliseconds to move that data from the
United States to Tokyo what folks have
been asking for it and so we've
announced the rollout of bigquery
general availability in Tokyo right so
it covers the the region so you don't
have to go across the the ocean and
allows you to keep your data in my
region of course there are use cases
where data sovereignty is applicable and
so we're going to continue to look into
other areas where that's applicable
we've rolled out several features around
transparency of bigquery the first one
is if you are using the bigquery UX
today you can in real time see progress
of your court you may have noticed that
already right it will say in there when
you run a query you will say your query
is on stage 5 of 12 and you will
actually show you a chart of what's
happening
that quarry the second is the quarry
slots is a unit of compute but that's
how the query executes it's it's
workloads you can actually see how many
slots have been consumed over the course
of quarry in Korean history that might
be useful for you for some of the folks
who are on our flat rate pricing model
it allows you to kind of calculate you
know how many slots you really need to
fill your workload and finally on the
bottom there one feature that is really
powerful for some of the more advanced
users is the ability to create resource
hierarchies so you can actually think of
the either as virtual clusters nested on
top of each other but they all share
resources you can have two separate
clusters one for the analytics team one
for your data science team and they all
have perfect isolation but when your
data science team goes on vacation those
resources are automatically available
for your analytics team so that no
resources are wasted and so here's an
example of a setup like that
well we've released some upgrades to our
monitoring in stackdriver
that allow you to track these
hierarchies and how they're being
consumed so this functionality is really
interesting and you know reach out to us
if you want to learn more about it self
service cost controls so folks talk to
us and tell us that sometimes there's
anxiety around you know with the with
the model of pricing that the courtney
has where you pay for every query there
is anxiety that you may run a query that
may be too expensive or maybe you'll run
too many queries well we were introduced
the cost controls a couple of years ago
actually to help you alleviate that name
now what you can do is you can set usage
limits you can do it per query or you
can do it as a daily budget this allows
you to kind of prevent the worst case
scenario in in case you really start
spending a lot of money and you have
really
you know made a mistake in your code
this protects you the first one is you
can set a per query cost limit so for
example you don't want any query that
processes more than 100 terabytes to
ever be ran in the query or you can set
that limit the second is you can set a
per user daily budget for example you
don't want any user to run more than 50
terabytes worth of queries in any single
day and this is of course is a rolling
window so you know you don't have to
wait until the end of the day to have
that reset and finally you can set per
project budgets as well right so you can
say in every budget every project only
gets access to you know 100 terabytes of
processing per day now what happens when
you reach that limit is you know bokura
starts giving you an error that says hey
you've exceeded your limit you can't we
can't run any more queries until your
tokens are refreshed until you start
using more so what we launched earlier
in in May is the automation of the per
project daily budget so you can go into
the bigquery console today you can set
the per project limit and this will take
effect in minutes instead of having to
go through support and things of that
and of course this is a very interesting
topic of discussion for our customers
for our users so we'd love to hear more
about what else you'd like to see from
these features
finally the query is being used for
folks from all parts with all kinds of
technologies right so people who are
used to relational databases people who
are used to Hadoop maybe they're using
Kafka would like to use all those
technologies in conjunction with the
court so we're really focusing on
interoperability the first feature I
want to talk about is partitions now
historically maybe six years ago when we
first started we didn't have any types
of partitions we had something called
table decorators actually table wild
cards table wild cards allow you to
query tables them actually table data
itself so if you have a thousand tables
they're all named a similar way you can
use this functionality to pick out which
tables you really want to court so
that's been really powerful for a long
time but throughout the years folks have
asked for partitioning functionality so
first we released a metadata what we
call natural partitions partitions on a
column that doesn't exist that had a
partition time predicate but since then
folks have asked for the ability to set
actual user based timestamp columns as
partition keys so in this example you
have a table that has four columns TS
and the other three columns that are
listed and we set TS as the partition
key so it's a date/time partition key so
when you are querying this table and you
say I want a TS to be a specific date
time we will actually go to just that
partition hopefully as as a the graphic
demonstrates so this is really a you
really useful feature it's also useful
when you are loading data into the query
or when you are trying to materialized
partition tables because you can
materialize lots and lots of partitions
with a single command right because we
will look at the timestamp of every
individual row and we'll put it in the
right partition hopefully that's useful
for you
the next feature is data manipulation
language on partition tables so we're
with release partitions will release the
a domination relation language now what
kind of merging these functions together
so you can actually edit partition
tables with DML so in this particular
example you see that you know in case I
want to take data from one partition and
do a filter where it says field 1 equals
21 and move that into a different
partition so just very basic DML
statement but allows you to do a lot
with your partition tables
hopefully you find that useful the next
feature is park' file format in just so
if you read the drama paper that was
released in 2010 there's a couple of
concepts that actually explained in
there the first one is the trommel
execution engine which is really what
powers bigquery and dromoland the quarry
are not the same thing the drama team is
the query team and they both kind of go
hand-in-hand but the other concept that
was explained in the paper is our file
format called column a o common go is a
common form file format that Julian and
other folks on on the park' team saw as
useful and externalized the parkade but
parquet is now a very ubiquitous file
format it's used essentially by everyone
who's leveraging HDFS hadoop mapreduce
even spark so part K is very powerful so
what we've enabled this year is the
ability to ingest our K directly into
the query it's very useful feature for a
couple of reasons
for for one just like Avro file format
it's binary so you're not going to have
you know weird collisions between utf-8
and ASCII whatever data you're loading
into the query from Bar K is strongly
typed the second is Bar K is highly
parallelizable so if you load
terabyte file of parquet into the quarry
we're gonna be able to split it into as
many chunks as we feel as necessary to
ingest that data into the query very
quickly
third is parquet has a schema inside of
the file so you don't need to define a
schema or we don't need to infer a
schema so that you can just take this
part a file and load it into that
bigquery table and we will figure out
all the details so it's really really
powerful we recommend this if you have
control over which files are loaded into
bigquery our K is a great way to get out
and of course one quick note on ingest
of data into the query ingest is you
know very compute intensive operation we
have to read your files we have to kind
of process them encode them into our
format compress them load them replicate
them all over the place typically with a
tip you know with technologies like
bigquery this compute capacity is the
same capacity that consumes your queries
so that if you're loading lots of data
into your technology your core capacity
may suffer with the query we have a
unique architecture where the query
capacity is entirely separate from the
ingest capacity so that no matter how
much that are you loading into the query
your queries don't suffer and of course
we also don't charge for these loads so
it's kind of like the best of both
worlds we don't charge for this and it
doesn't affect your query capacity we
feel like our customers benefit from
this greatly and of course there are
many other formats that are being used
and in the world out there and we're
going to be announcing more soon and
please let us know if you have a file
format that we don't support you know
we'd love to see which ones are popular
and which ones we should support in the
future the last feature out of the major
ones that I want to talk about is our
continuous updates to the symbol drivers
to the ODBC and JDBC drivers that we
work with simple to put together
well these updates happen we have rather
regularly these days so over
we always want folks to use these
drivers as a gateway to the query so
some of the things that we've been
working on is things like support for
partitions support for DML and DDL
support for CMAC customer manage
encryption keys so everything that the
QWERTY has we want in the ODBC and JDBC
drivers so they're continuously being
updated as bigquery features are rolling
out we are also working on making these
drivers faster so over the past six
months or so we've increased performance
by roughly 60% on these drivers and
we're gonna continue to focus on that
and finally we want these drivers to be
mature and stable so our customers kind
of get the best experience this way and
one final thing that I didn't really
talk about here is there are there's
much more that's happening inside of
bigquery as you can see you may look in
our release notes you may notice that
we've increased a whole lot of quotas so
for example the bro in cell size limit
specifically for CSV and JSON files has
increased from 10 megabytes to a hundred
megabytes so it's just easier for you to
load data into the court and the maximum
number of petitions per table have been
increased to 4,000 and so on and so
forth the other thing to point out there
is we've extended our sequel
functionality to have the error function
and the safe prefix so you can handle
errors a little bit better inside of
your sequel statements now a quick segue
onto quotas the query is a multi-tenant
system so a lot of the subsystems are
shared and you know there are just like
an alien technology there are anti
patterns in the query there are things
that you as a customer are is allowed to
do that may not work for you if you
continue to do that through scale and
that essentially is the truth whenever
Tecna
so in order for us to to to kind of work
with you in the best way to use the
query we have these quotas so quarters
are there to protect you guys and
they're there to protect us as well that
said if you have specific use cases
where you know certain quotas need to be
raised police come talk to us we're
we're always looking for ways to improve
this particular user experience right so
the the quotas are not immutable many of
them can be edited so it would be good
if you if you do end up in situations
where quotas are are you can do end up
in situations where you you're hitting
quarters come talk to us it may be well
we'll work on that so so far the query
has you know to recap release the number
of features of course we we have lots of
engineers and we have lots of folks
working on more features so there will
be many many more and we'll do a Molly
recap just like this where we'll walk
through all the features that we're
releasing moving forward but so far
these are the features we've released in
2018 again please do come talk to us
about these and and others that you may
need that we haven't released and you
know we'd love to to see how we can help
you and to wrap up we as I mentioned
before have our conference in July 12 24
and 26 in San Francisco I will be there
vast majority of the equity leadership
and engineers will be there and we'd
love to talk to you so please come find
us we'll have a booth we'll have
sessions we'd love to hear from you and
great well stay tuned for live Q&A we'll
we'll be back in less than a minute
you
welcome back now it's time for the Q&A
we took some questions from the audience
and if you have more questions please
again reach out to us the first one is
when are some of these beta features
that I've talked about gonna go GA
general availability well let me tell
you how our features kind of get
released into general availability it's
kind of like the maturity of scale by
the time features hit general
availability they have a support plan or
we have SL A's we have our site
reliability engineers working on these
features so they are fully supported
they lock down and we're fully behind it
by the time these features are beta
there they're sexually locked down as
well we're kind of from beta to GA we're
working on maturity we're working on you
know performance scalability just making
sure that everything that that the user
experience is really phenomenal there
but by the time features are beta
they're fairly mature away and before
they go beta of course we have alpha and
we have early access programs and you
know we're always looking for folks to
try these features out before they go
beta as well so it really depends on the
feature from beta to GA it's rare that
we have features that take more than a
year to go from beta to GA but a lot of
these take one or two quarters generally
but a lot of folks are using these
features in data because they're
incredibly useful already I'm not gonna
stop you next question is how can I find
out about upcoming features well we have
our blog posts we have twitter we have
our release notes so we try to maintain
a presence around what you know - up we
were trying to update our customers and
our users with what's happening but you
know we do have a road map and we do
have other features that are coming up
so to learn more about that reach out to
your account folks or reach out to us
directly to get these updates third
question
I need to update thousands of rows on
the table but the limit for DML
statement is only 200 that's correct
so today a per table limit for how many
DML statements you can execute is 200
but as I mentioned in one of the earlier
slides we don't limit how many rows can
be affected by any of these statements
so you can any of those 200 statements
can execute you know millions or
billions or trillions of mutations you
can you can work on the whole table all
at once if you'd like to so again a best
practice for the query is to batch these
updates and deletes and inserts into
into singular requests so you can update
thousands of rows in a single table
using our correlated updates using a
sub-query in a single statement or a
couple of statements but again if you
have specific use cases were or specific
places where you need these statements
raised please come talk to us maybe
there's a property you can use case and
we can help you
what partitioning schema do you
recommend so we have really three types
of ways to partition your data the first
one is you can just shard your data what
I mean by that is you can create a table
for every quote-unquote partition so you
can create a table for every single day
and name it so right you can say games
2018 or 601 games 2806 or two games 2018
oh six oh three what we have as I
mentioned is the ability to kind of
query specific tables so you can say I
want to query all tables where the month
is July and so we will kind of seek all
those tables and we will only select the
tables that fit your predicate so that's
one way of doing that the next way is
using our natural partitions which is a
metadata column a date/time column that
isn't a column that is inside of your
table but it's a metadata call and it
uses a partition
predicate the repetition date predicate
that's also one way of doing things but
I think the most useful way at least
from what our customers tell us is this
user-specified
column partition so you can you can
actually set up a table where one of
your columns where one of your values is
the partition key so you can say this
timestamp column is my partition and
please use that this is really useful
because again you can load data into
bigquery into a table into multiple
partitions all at once or you can run a
select into statement that writes data
to multiple partitions all at once last
question is how can I submit feature
requests and get my questions answered
so I touched upon this a few times
there's a few avenues where continuously
working on improving our communication
with our users we want to hear from you
so we're very very active on Stack
Overflow we're very active on Twitter
and of course we have something called
an issue tracker where you can actually
submit your own feature requests and we
have multiple plans for support you know
from all the way out to dedicated
support engineers who are working just
for you and those folks are there to
help you with any issues you might have
helped you with any issue any features
that you might want to have and you want
us to know about and these folks can
help facilitate any roadmap discussions
with our team great stay tuned for the
new for the next session see chat
wrangling your data with cloud data prep